you
all right well this one
came up pretty fast 31 in here
10 seconds to go
all right I am gosu v2 version 2
I think I just saw the corner of my eye
somebody did in fact follow up with the
in the same
they went in for
the grab Banco
someone actually created that this prawn
is super valuable
super valuable it's my favorite pawn in
this position he's doubled but I love
him he's going to be a monster soon
should knee shouldn't he be a monster
let's go here
this guy
can't allow this to hit too easily
I guess we get a flight square now
oh actually I'm just realizing I have
enough pieces on this
like Miss counted here could take could
take here there's a check but I could
just step up
here could drop
encounter the Queen I'm up a lot of time
threaten me keep pressure on that pawn
and we got we got mates we got the mates
all right we got the W
yeah that's I don't know I think they
need to strike a little bit sooner once
I had those double pawns
maybe stir something up once it got a
little bit under control
as mentioned that d6 pawn controls what
would normally be excellent outposts for
whites Knights Han sack is the opponent
all right we're looking for a fancy
fishing pole mate
maybe one day Bishop takes Knight takes
h5h for Knight g3 chop chop discover
check stuff
let's start with c5 here I could have
given a check
I would have been better as soon as h3
Queen h4
let's be a bit more on top of things
here how about we go straight in for
this now and hop in and look to secure
the night next good control light square
control good harmony between structure
and Bishop
way down on time on sock
likely new to the time control
okay
he's going nowhere now let's just close
it
yeah no time
determine my space my spacebar doesn't
work
is in first 47 are now in here okay cool
brambly
okay bramble ii
bramble be alright let's try Samish
mmm let's let's long
the H pun let's go here
me upon
yes
queenside and still continue with this
even if it costs upon its nuts not
costing upon just want to peel open the
H file let's shut down the bish up in
this way and they're not moving with him
let's open up the H file take here offer
a clean exchange I want to get to e6
take with the bishop and throw a punch
and now this is where I want to be
that's a killer bishop made on the spot
actually that's how much of a killer he
was and even realize how deadly he was
what'd I just say there that was too
many deadlies in too little time
all right I got eight a lot of us up
here with fire all right let's try c4
mmm-hmm let's go here so a bit of a
reverse Sicilian we could go fishing
from this angle take towards the center
I keep my queen
eyeballing that square we're gonna go
fishing the main threat
fishing pole
I sense that the player was a little new
to the variant I saw that question mark
I thought it's time for fishing pole
stuff
24 bankster
mariya let's try fishing from this angle
maybe
Linna it's been a while you know and I
don't go fishing I get asked why haven't
you been using the fishing pole lately
so you got to do that once in a while
throw a punch at the pond all right I'm
just gonna glue the bishop in there
defend here that would have been nice as
well I just want to develop though could
take here let's do it now double attack
against the rook and Knight he's pinned
and it's just falling
castle I could have captured the name
let's do it now okay I'm mopping up
everything here he's a little
floundering tactic
I guess here here
anything
fast flight square
and I guess here smash throughout this
square soon we're almost there and this
is actually mating
okay many different combos you could
pull off when you have a boatload of
material there 22 minutes left 53 are
now in here who's next
trackpad irate trackpad let's try a
caro-kann probably a favorite of mine in
bullet
um I could I could grab that pond take
advantage of a pin got that covered
they're gonna go in for this that might
actually be something it's chewing on it
hmm I'll take with the bishop
you know I was fearful of just I didn't
want to play here and I don't know
something felt very slow Bishop d6
there's Knight takes here
develop the Queen get all my pieces
playing I'm be to do I really want that
let's go here keep my structure Knight
a5
instead of moving rook 95 into C form
trackpad is way down on time 12 seconds
not going to do it
just trade hmm guess we'll hit the Queen
flight square I don't want to repair
their structure am I in trouble maybe
okay I don't mind seeing that
got the night and we got
works there down on time I know maybe it
was a connection issue or something that
was a an excessive amount of time to be
thinking there okay 20 minute mark
this is probably all we're going to end
up getting right around 55 players
I'm goes to v2 is in there with the game
four seed versus trackpad now
a little bit of a delay there for a
pairing maybe we try the Grob I think we
did earlier now let's take and play here
I don't want to CD for um I guess here
they lining up that move
upon
yeah I do anima
let's go here Queen takes pawn yeah you
do have that so you got a good point
there
underdeveloped I think I'm consolidating
though just need two moves that's all I
want
mm-hmm and I could play that I'm on the
night Roxy - Rexy - is very scary I have
this move I can move my knight in then
Castle Knight here Knight f3 there's
rook see one night b3 defends night b3
eyes up c5
probably won't have to be careful
jeez
holy cow I gotta make a move
I just want to cut off things here
God do I think that this is a I don't
know what I'm doing here
I gotta go faster
no-no-no
I gotta go time Burger land
I should have captured the rook
I'll get a second chance third chance a
fourth chance oh my god I was really in
a like it was a 5minute game mentality
do not know what that was about
okay
um I felt like
time burned me at the end there they
were a little bit faster I I could have
got smoked
all right dead bones unknown here we go
mmm we could go fishing again
no limit no limit fishing okay let's try
D five one go hop right in there
give me a passer
it's a tough pawn to track down I could
take care of this um let's go here
don't you want a castle I don't think I
want a castle something scares me about
that Thanks
I could take you with check oh then I
could jump in there but I have this
right
oh that's what's check
I don't care if they take that pond I
don't care you take my rook I wanna get
rid that night this is the way to get
rid of the night by force
9si for setting everything the whole
farm dart to take with the king
I'll go here okay let's just
sure this pond can't move
you know take their boat they got back
rank
to deal with who is here have the queen
drop back I'm on g2
g2 is under fire
nearly getting made it if I'm not
careful they're done on time though 28
1862 in here
okay let's see we get
had shiitake I see up there some game
just finished
risk let's try you for Sark Sartre agloe
is in the twitch chat I just see in the
corner my eye
alright each three Bishop e2 Queen d2
dark square Bishop exchange sensible
probably just take and then maybe try to
win this guy playing the dark squares
right now I think I need to clamp down
some that's probably a good move this
looks interesting
with the ensuing dark square control
upon for the exchange he's a monster on
c5 just takes away some squares and
actually here is a Royal fork and a half
mmm that's hitting a lot
Bishop out and then I guess the way to
victory is to push this guy
actually there's no rush let's
centralize the king and maybe we open it
up in a different way
you target over here
many different approaches
I guess we'll stop this guy put a pond
on dark I didn't mean to do that
so one King and pawn endgame even if I
lose that
so one sneak
move left to Perry there we go
no sneaky moves now
save all the puns
boatload of time remaining no stalemates
no stalemates no stalemates i always
check and there's not going to be
stealing
here we go back to tournament land okay
well we're beyond the halfway point only
13 minutes left
64 in there shiitake on board um how
about a five I do not play e5 often and
especially not in one minute games
let's castle marshal some marshal
I do not know what I'm doing in this
line very difficult to play fast
um let's go here I feel like I want to
allow this move one of the more
beautiful moves so Knight to e4 and
embarrass your Bishop taking with the
pond light squares
okay
and the bishop
I don't know maybe we camp out on b3 one
day throw a strike at the night now's
the time
easy to miss lateral move got him
he's a machine here on d5 what is he not
doing he's a rock cannot be challenged
on a light square dark square bishop is
not gonna bother him no ponds are
bothering him 36 24 22 less than 12 all
righty
trackpad again let's try see four
against trackpad
nine seconds we got a countdown here
turns red soon I think after seven on
their end it turns red I guess an
exchange Slav is what we have
transposition okay
minor piece game c-file game is what we
have
sake with the rook okay I'll grab a
little bit of space I'll put them in a
pin this Bishop has gone astray can I
get away with taking here if they push
it's interesting let's give it a go
tough to work out the details here
does that work
suppose this and then Knight takes d5
that should be painful
this is hitting really hard that's
what's check I could follow up with f4
stop Queen takes h2 we're looking at e5
next in this night here and then here is
the idea actually with that set I should
have played e5 instead of F form Queen
takes and then here straightaway I guess
in the end we're still going to get it
on the Queen and threatening a
million-one
F for not needed
they resigned back determine less than
10 got 40 with fire 24 22 22
all righty
Kronus ICC mm okay I guess Knight f6 g6
something a little bit different d6 c5
okay that's a pretty passive post for
the C pawn
let's jump in now I want my bishop to
see the world
and I'll take okay
that maybe was more accurate
night each for maybe move let's stop
this move
Changez what I want um I'll dance around
keep a night on the board still
let's develop the night
I'm expecting a queen exchange soon
wanna get in b5 I'm going to be pushing
in the center
want to be files open I don't want to
move my night too soon I may just be
running into a five with tempo
so looks ugly but I'm gonna do it I want
to stop their plan put my rook on B -
maybe here we go
is more active let's keep them around
let's push the pond I guess here give me
a passer
you
I want to be able to get over here
that's why I brought my queen like that
my knight is a monster it's connected
right here I could just duck huh my
queen trapped really close to being
trapped that's not even a good preme of
holy cow was that the guy that should
have I felt that uh he should have beat
me in that other game
played slow against again against that
guy
I think man
okay well that was that was a different
kind of position different pawn
structure we were working with
what to do
I'll grab a little space nc5 Queen c2
I'm expecting f6
here maybe I jump in I like that idea I
could go here now for I could go here
first hit the Queen no time for f4 I'm
not going to take I just I'm gonna duck
this threat yeah let's keep him around
I'd see five I have covered
let's just play over here probably want
to get rid of the knight he's that much
of a bother
hmm all right let's take their dark
square bishop I guess
I don't want to see this pawn move
get four
for c-5 I guess I want to watch out for
these advances that night move is going
to bother me oh boy
and I got a break over here
she'll probably have played this much
sooner I don't want to but I don't wanna
give this pawn to move this night should
have played here much sooner think yeah
night 8 night h4 there's no time though
I only have a second
as pawns running
they're down on time back determined 48
only five minutes left
okay
let's see we get in the final few games
trackpad again
nine eight and this is taking a while
something's different
played trackpad many times and usually
much much faster than this
to do that okay
okay
attention
alright now I'll take they're ready to
take their
let's see don't go here I have two
pieces covering the night
take the night out if he goes here maybe
this will get this rook here
could be annoying or bishop they're a
little scary to say the least
very a bit of a loose position also I
could have captured this pawn let's back
up I think I want to drop my Queen home
okay
this move and everything's cool why that
moved though let's just put a knight in
the center
now maybe I should have gone with the
other night so I could flush him away do
this now
slowly untangling and I think I'm close
to better now I could just go here even
on the clock we're really close to
taking this night out the bishop backs
up be six is hit pon grabber isn't he
trapped though you get three pawns
though yeah that's what they're going
for
I have that covered
you
shut down the bishop
well they're down on time and they
definitely kicked it into a different
gear towards the end there okay one or
two more games
bullet newb
I guess b4 that's different
okay
have some space go with four and let's
keep that guy around okay they're really
asking for trouble now this is a killer
night
okay
big trouble here now things are getting
broken down I have a check first and
then this move order
pac-man
scare the queen away just looking at
something fancy like queen takes bishop
takes not quite there
not sure what I'm doing here okay now
I'm sure what I'm doing
let's jump in here I need a flight
square still okay that's a pin that they
cannot get out of pile up on it back to
tournament really gonna get one more in
which will not be counting for the
tournament standings let's see who we
get pairings are shut down at the
30-second mark somewhere around there Oh
No
or are we even gonna get a game there we
go I guess it's Sicilian
let's challenge him straightaway um are
they dealing with this idea I get the
rook
castled
just picked up a rook
run away and let's just develop
pick up a 5 even might be close to mate
Knight to f3 Queen
to help me
I guess we'll take the rip
very close to mate very close
okay I'm okay on time where's the Queen
going by the way covering a lot of
ground let's connect the rooks now back
rank stuff knight on d4 bishops I'm
protected I can move the knight
we'll do like this I'm on here
and may very soon I have this square
covered let's check discover check and
then we have mink okay that's going to
do it
69 players in all that one did not count
for the tournament 56 37 35 top three
let's have a quick look at all the pages
many new players in this one did the
hyper bullet was the one that was
running so was not up for hyperbole a
Cree determinant is what we got this
time around okay to the sixty eight of
you in good games all
you